I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello, lady. Hi.
我是珍娜·费舍（Jenna Fischer），我是安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们专门为你带来了终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和大量闺蜜故事，带你深入了解《办公室》的世界。我们是《办公室女士》6.0版。你好，女士。嗨。
Happy Wednesday. Do I look like I'm stiff in my neck a little? No. Are you? I'm a little stiff. Did you sleep weird? I slept weird, but also I've been traveling a lot, and I fell asleep on the plane in a weird position. That's never good.
周三快乐。我看起来脖子有点僵硬吗？没有。你呢？我有点僵硬。你睡觉姿势很奇怪吗？我睡觉姿势很奇怪，但我也一直在到处旅行，而且我在飞机上以一种奇怪的姿势睡着了。那可真不好。
Never good. But also, the last time I traveled, I think I needed to up my travel game because I flew with Rain. Rain Wilson, you guys. He's one of my favorite people to travel with. He's a very courteous traveler. A gentleman. Gentleman. Help me with my bag.
绝对不好。不过，我上次旅行时，觉得我需要提升我的旅行水平，因为我和雷恩一起坐飞机。雷恩·威尔逊（Rainn Wilson），各位。他是和我一起旅行最喜欢的人之一。他是个非常体贴的旅客。一位绅士。绅士。帮我拿包。
Here's an example, right? We got like a cup of hot tea to go. And as I'm carrying it around, he goes, your tea bag. has been in that cup for a long time. I think you should take the tea bag out. Don't you want to take the tea bag out out? I was like, I do, but I'm holding too many things. And so he took the tea bag out for me. Yeah. These are the types of things. Details. Here's the thing. I guarantee you rain does not have a sore neck today. Because that man travels with a really big neck pillow. No, he does not. Yes, he does. And he puts it on the minute he gets on the plane and his neck disappears. And then he's just a
这是一个例子，对吧？我们拿了一杯外带热茶。当我拿着它走来走去时，他说，你的茶包在那个杯子里泡了很久了。我觉得你应该把茶包拿出来。你难道不想把茶包拿出来吗？我说，我想拿，但我手里拿了太多东西。于是他帮我把茶包拿了出来。是的。就是这种类型的事情。细节。事情是这样的，我向你保证，雷恩今天脖子绝对不酸痛。因为那家伙旅行时带着一个非常大的颈枕。不，他没有。不，他真的有。而且他一上飞机就戴上，然后他的脖子就消失了。接着他就变成了一个
little floating head. Please tell me you took a picture of this. It's the biggest neck pillow I've ever seen. I didn't even know. Do they come in multiple sizes? This sounds like what it looks like. It's not. He's got it in his bag and then he falls asleep and his face is like wedged in it.
小小的漂浮的头。请告诉我你拍了照片。那是我见过最大的颈枕。我甚至都不知道。它们有多种尺寸吗？听起来就像它看起来的那样。并不是。他把它放在包里，然后睡着了，他的脸就像卡在里面一样。
Oh, and then he puts his AirPods in? Yeah. Like the AirPods with the string. Just a regular. What are they called? They're not called AirPods. They're not cordless. No, they're not cordless.
哦，然后他戴上AirPods？对。就像带线的AirPods。只是普通的。它们叫什么来着？它们不叫AirPods。它们不是无线的。对，它们不是无线的。
He puts him in his ears. Okay. Right? And then he puts it into the little TV, and then he puts headphones over those. Okay. And then his neck pillow. So he's wearing two pairs of headphones and a neck pillow. I'm showing Jenna a picture.
他把它们塞进耳朵里。对吧？然后把它插进小电视里，接着他在那些外面又戴了耳机。好吧。然后是他的颈枕。所以他戴了两副耳机和一个颈枕。我正在给珍娜看一张照片。
That's pretty great. Yeah. Anyway, I'm sure he doesn't have a sore neck. I might have to stop making fun of him and get his giant inflatable neck pillow. It looks like something you plug in and blow up. He had to blow it up? No, he didn't. But that's what it looks like to me.
那真是太棒了。对。总之，我确信他的脖子一点也不酸。我可能得停止嘲笑他，去买他那个巨大的充气颈枕了。它看起来就像那种你需要插电并吹气的东西。他得把它吹起来吗？不，他没有。但它给我的感觉就是那样。
That's how big it was. Okay. Anyway, sorry. I've got so many neck pillows over the years and I never use them ever. They just become this thing I'm carrying. Well, I don't know. Rain uses his. Sam, do you use a neck pillow?
它有那么大。好吧。总之，抱歉。这些年来我买过好多颈枕，但我从来没用过。它们最后都成了我带着的累赘。好吧，我不知道。雷恩会用他的。萨姆，你用颈枕吗？
I do and then I forget them. I have probably eight or nine in my closet somewhere. Exactly. I get to the airport. I realize I don't have one. I go through a whole thing in my head. Should I get one? I spend the $25 at, what is it, City News or whatever the airport shop is.
我用，然后就把它们忘在哪了。我的衣柜里某处大概有八、九个吧。没错。我到了机场。我意识到我没有带。我在脑子里经历了一番天人交战。我该买一个吗？我花25美元在那个什么城市新闻（City News）还是别的什么机场商店里买一个。
And then I bring it on the plane. I use it for like four minutes. Yep. I know I'm saddled with it. Yeah. Yeah. Well, listen, everyone, we have a great episode of Office ladies today. Randall Park stopped by our studio.
然后我把它带上飞机。我只用了大概四分钟。没错。我知道我被它给套牢了。对。对。好了，听着，各位，我们今天有一期非常棒的《办公室女士》节目。兰道尔·朴（Randall Park）来到了我们的工作室。
We have a great conversation with him. You all know that Randall Park played Jim's friend Steve, who helped Jim and Pam play the ultimate prank on Dwight in the cold open of season nine's Andy's ancestry. We talk all about it. We talk all about that. We hear about his time. the set, how he got the role. But then we also just talk about his amazing career and all of these different fantastic characters he's played over the years. We're big fans. But guess what?
我们与他进行了一场精彩的对话。大家都知道兰道尔·朴饰演吉姆的朋友史蒂夫，他在第九季开场戏《安迪的祖先》中帮助吉姆和帕姆对德怀特实施了终极恶作剧。我们对此进行了深入探讨。我们聊了所有这些。我们听他讲述了他在片场的时光，他是如何得到这个角色的。但随后我们也聊了他惊人的职业生涯以及他这些年来扮演的所有这些不同的奇妙角色。我们是他的超级粉丝。但你猜怎么着？
Not just that. He did our fan chit-chat question with us. So without further ado, let's get to it. Randall Park, welcome to office ladies. Thank you for having me. It's an honor. We're excited that you're going to join us for our fan chit-chat question this week. Yeah, yeah. I'm excited. All right. It's so lovely to see you, too, by the way. It's so nice to see you. It's been a while.
不仅如此。他还和我们一起做了粉丝闲聊问答题。所以话不多说，我们马上开始。兰道尔·朴，欢迎来到《办公室女士》。谢谢你们邀请我。这是我的荣幸。我们很高兴你能加入我们本周的粉丝闲聊问答。好啊，好啊。我很兴奋。好的。顺便说一句，见到你真好。见到你太高兴了。好久不见了。
It has. All right, are you ready for a chit-chat? I'm nervous, but let's do it. Okay, well, this is from Joey R in Rochester, New York, who says, I was at a company retreat years ago where they had us play some icebreaker games. There was one question we all had to answer that proved more spirited than the rest. If I'm ever at a boring dinner party, I like to pull this one out and it always gets people going. It's really simple.
确实好久不见。好了，你准备好闲聊了吗？我很紧张，但我们开始吧。好的，这个提问来自纽约州罗切斯特市的乔伊·R（Joey R），他说：几年前我在公司举办的一场静修活动上，他们让我们玩了一些破冰游戏。有一个问题我们所有人都得回答，结果比其他问题引发了更多热烈的讨论。如果我参加无聊的晚宴，我喜欢抛出这个问题，它总能活跃气氛。这真的很简单。
I thought you guys might like it. Here we go. Rank your favorite forms of potato. To help you out, here's a list. You could also just pick your top three. People get really passionate about their potatoes. Okay, I will just say this. Joey, this list is very long.
我想你们可能会喜欢。我们开始吧。给你们最喜欢的马铃薯做法排个名。为了帮你们一把，这里有个清单。你们也可以只选出前三名。大家对马铃薯可是相当有热情的。好吧，我只想说这个。乔伊，这个清单真的很长。
So I think we'll read them and then pick our favorite three. Yes. Okay, top three. Okay, generate them off. Here are ways to eat a potato. French fries, tater tots. Latka. Baked, scalloped, roasted, potato chip, mashed, hash-browned, or noki. I forgot yokey as a potato. That's right. That's a good one. That's right. That's right.
所以我想我们先把它们读出来，然后选出我们最喜欢的三个。好的。好的，前三名。好的，开始生成。以下是吃马铃薯的方法。炸薯条，炸薯球。土豆饼。烤土豆，奶油焗土豆，烤土豆块，薯片，土豆泥，薯饼，或是意式土豆面疙瘩（gnocchi）。我差点忘了意式土豆面疙瘩也是土豆制品。没错。这是一个好选择。没错。没错。
That's sneaky potato. I have to add one. What? Well, we have baked, but we don't have twice-baked, and I personally really love a twice-baked potato, and it's going to be in my three. What's it twice-to-bake? You bake the potato, then you scoop all the stuff out, you mix it together with like some cheese and milk and stuff and chives, and then you put it back in the skin and then you bake it again. Oh, and it crusts over a little bit. Oh, okay. I've never had that. Yeah.
那是隐藏的土豆。我必须补充一个。什么？嗯，我们有烤土豆，但我们没有二次烘烤土豆，我个人非常喜欢二次烘烤土豆，它绝对会在我的前三名里。什么是二次烘烤？你先把土豆烤熟，然后把里面的东西全部挖出来，和一些奶酪、牛奶、香葱之类的东西拌在一起，接着再把它放回土豆皮里，然后重新烤一次。哦，表面还会形成一层脆皮。哦，好吧。我从来没吃过那个。对。
Oh, they're real good. Okay. So that's kind of like, yeah, that's why I spake. I get it. I also want to just say, Jenna, that should you ever want a job being like the announcer on a game show, I think you got it. Did I sound like that? You did. It sound like, well, you like that.
哦，它们真的很好吃。好吧。所以这有点像，对，这就是为什么叫二次烘烤。我明白了。我只想说，珍娜，如果你哪天想当游戏节目的播音员，我觉得你完全可以胜任。我刚才听起来那样吗？你确实是。听起来就像，嗯，你懂的。
moment in a million dollar pyramid where I was like, the answers are, french fries. Yeah, and I was riveted the whole time. You are? Yeah. Yeah. I had a list. I was in. Yeah.
百万富翁金字塔（Million Dollar Pyramid）里的那个时刻，当时我说，答案是，炸薯条。对，我全程都被吸引住了。你是吗？对。对。我心里有一份清单。我完全沉浸其中。对。
Okay. Top three. Who wants to go first? I mean, number one for me and also on that list. And I would think for a lot of people is French fries. Yes. Is there a better way to make a potato? No.
好的。前三名。谁想先来？我是说，对我和这个清单上的排名来说，第一名毫无疑问是炸薯条。没错。难道还有比这更好的土豆做法吗？没有。
No. I love my French fries with season salt. Like, if you're anywhere, would they offer that? Yeah. I take it. And any kind, you know, shoe string, waffle. I mean, that's a whole other list, right? That's true.
没有。我喜欢加了调味盐的炸薯条。如果在什么地方，他们提供这个？对。我就会选它。而且任何种类，你知道的，细长条的，华夫格的。我是说，那是另一张清单了，对吧？确实如此。
How to have your fry. Yeah, but any fry. Even wedge? Wedge. I love a good wedge. Really? I love a good wedge. To me, there's not enough ratio between, like, potato and fry.
怎么吃你的薯条。对，但任何薯条都行。甚至土豆角？土豆角。我超爱不错的土豆角。真的吗？我喜欢不错的土豆角。在我看来，土豆和薯条之间的比例不太对。
When it's in a wedge, it's too much potato to me. I almost see it as like a baked potato and a fry. Mm-hmm. You know, kind of in one. It's a grab and go. Bake potato. And then I need my French fries with ranch or mayonnaise. That's fine?
当它是土豆角时，对我来说土豆肉太多了。我几乎觉得它既像烤土豆又像薯条。嗯-hmm。你知道的，结合在一起。这是一种随手可拿的烤土豆。然后我的炸薯条得蘸牧场酱（ranch）或者蛋黄酱。这样可以吗？
Manage, yeah. You can have it. Okay, okay. All right. Are we all agreeing that French fry is number one? Are we in agreement? Are you in on French fries? French fries are a solid number two for me.
蛋黄酱，可以。你可以选它。好吧，好吧。好了。大家都同意炸薯条是第一名吗？我们意见一致吗？你赞成炸薯条吗？炸薯条对我来说稳居第二。
Oh. In first prize is a baked potato specifically from Wendy's. The amount of sour cream and cheese on it, you have no idea it's a potato. Okay. Wait, does Wendy's have a potato bar? Sam, are you making it? that or is it coming at you with all that on there? It's all coming to you as a chewy, sticky goodness. Wait, Wendy still has baked. They do. Yes, they do. I didn't know that. I didn't
哦。第一名是温蒂汉堡（Wendy's）的烤土豆。上面浇的酸奶油和奶酪的量，你根本想象不出它是个土豆。好吧。等等，温蒂汉堡有土豆吧吗？萨姆，那是你自己加的，还是它端上来时上面就铺满了那些东西？全都是端上来时就自带的那种软糯黏稠的美味。等等，温蒂汉堡现在还有烤土豆吗？有的。是的，他们有。我不知道这个。我没有
chill it. It's great. Give it a shot next time you're there. Okay. Okay. Okay. All right. Well, so you like it because it's kind of taking you further away from the potato, if anything, because you're just putting all this junk on. At a certain point, it's just spoonfuls of sour cream and cheese and bacon. That's what I like in a potato. So that's zero potato. What about just the bowl of? sour cream and bacon. There you go. Okay. That's how Michael Scott would eat. That's his ice cream. Incidentally.
冷落它。它很棒。下次你去的时候尝尝看。好吧。好吧。好吧。好吧，所以你喜欢它，是因为它在某种程度上让你离土豆本身更远了，因为你只是在上面堆满了各种垃圾。到了一定程度，它就只是几勺酸奶油、奶酪和培根了。这就是我喜欢土豆的地方。所以那是零土豆。那只来一碗酸奶油和培根怎么样？这就对了。好吧。迈克尔·斯科特（Michael Scott）就会这么吃。那是他的冰淇淋。顺便一提。
Okay. What's your number two, Jenna? My number two, you know what? Every time, I forget about them all the time because I'm not a child. But anytime they're available, I love a tater tot. I really do love it that way because it's like a hash brown, but tie me. Then I can pop it in my mouth. So I'm going to go tater tot. I'm going to go french fry and then tater tot. It's my wife. My wife is the same. I'm not that into Tator Tots. For me, it'll be baked potato.
好的。你的第二名是什么，珍娜？我的第二名，你知道吗？每次我总是忘记它们，因为我不是小孩子。但只要有它们，我真的超爱炸薯球（tater tot）。我真的很喜欢那种做法，因为它就像薯饼，但是是一小块一小块的。然后我可以把它塞进嘴里。所以我选炸薯球。我选炸薯条，然后是炸薯球。这绝对是我的菜。我太太也一样。我其实没那么迷炸薯球。对我来说，会是烤土豆。
Bake potato is your number two. Yeah. Big potato for me too. Yeah. I love a baked potato. I had one last night. Oh, it's the best. My husband will put like a little bit of like olive oil or butter on the outside and then
烤土豆是你的第二名。对。烤土豆对我也一样。对。我超级喜欢烤土豆。我昨晚刚吃了一个。哦，这是最棒的。我丈夫会在外面抹一点橄榄油或黄油，然后
the big kind of chunky salt. And so the skin has that. So you eat the skin. I will when he does that. Yeah. Oh, I love the skin when you've oiled it up and all that. Yeah. Exactly.
撒上那种大颗粒的粗盐。所以土豆皮就有那种味道。因此你会连皮一起吃。他那样做的时候我会吃的。对。哦，我很喜欢抹了油之后的土豆皮，所有这些。对。没错。
That's what she said. I know. There's going to be a lot. I think, in this potato talk. Okay, so we know Sam's number two is French fries. What is our number three? Mine is twice-baked potato. That's your number three?
她刚才就是这么说的。我懂。我觉得这次关于土豆的讨论里会有很多这种双关语。好吧，所以我们知道萨姆的第二名是炸薯条。我们的第三名是什么？我的是二次烘烤土豆。那是你的第三名？
Yes. You know, I love a good breakfast hash brown. Okay. Love it. You know, I really like a good boiled potato. Was that on there? It's not. Oh, but neither was twice baked.
是的。你知道的，我超爱一份美味的早餐薯饼。好吧。超爱。你知道，我真的很喜欢一份煮土豆。那个在清单上吗？没有。哦，不过二次烘烤也没有在上面。
Yeah, like a, you know, like a boiled potato with like rosemary and salt and... Some but... Yeah. It's how the English prepare their potatoes, I really enjoy that. Yeah. My mom would always do some boiled potatoes. Yeah, those are good too. You guys, I think we crushed this potato list.
对，就像那种，你知道的，加了迷迭香和盐的煮土豆……还有一些……对。那是英国人准备土豆的方法，我真的很喜欢。对。我妈妈总是会做一些水煮土豆。对，那些也很好吃。各位，我觉得我们把这个土豆清单给彻底搞定啦。
Well, Sam, what's number three? Tater tots. Tater tots. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay. All right. Before we take a break, I want to say something possibly controversial about potatoes. I don't love mashed potatoes.
好吧，萨姆，第三名是什么？炸薯球。炸薯球。对，对，对，对。好吧。好吧。在我们休息之前，关于土豆，我想说一件可能会引起争议的事。我其实不太喜欢土豆泥。
Oh. Yeah, we're done. I'll see you guys later. Yeah, thanks for coming to. We've been friends a long time, and it ends today. I love mashed potatoes. How can you not love mashed potatoes? Is it a texture thing?
哦。好吧，我们聊完了。回头见，各位。对，谢谢你们来。我们做了很久的朋友，而友情今天就要结束了。我超爱土豆泥。你怎么会不爱土豆泥呢？是因为口感问题吗？
It's, I don't know. What about mashed potatoes with gravy? Come on. Oh, come on. Yeah. With the scoop and then the scoop of the gravy in the little, like, pond. Yes. I liked that when I was younger, but something has happened to my potato palate, and I just, it's a pass.
这，我不知道。加了肉汁的土豆泥呢？拜托。哦，拜托。对。中间挖个小洞，然后把肉汁倒进那个小“池塘”里。是的。我年轻的时候挺喜欢那样的，但我的土豆味蕾发生了一些变化，所以现在，这绝对是个“不”。
Do you just equate it with, like, kind of, it's just, juvenile. It's like too... No, it's Thanksgiving. Is it too many starches for your all-protein weightlifting diet? It's that I'd rather roast them than have them mashed. In my family, this is the big thing, because everybody else likes mashed potatoes. And sometimes I hit a wall and I roast the potatoes and it's a whole thing at dinner. They're like, oh, mom roasts to the potatoes tonight. This is so funny. I have the complete opposite. I'm like the one that loves mashed potatoes and my kids don't. And I'm like, how can you not love mashed potatoes? How is this possible? It sounds to me like potato eating, we need to switch families.
你是不是把它等同于那种，呃，有点太幼稚了？它是不是太……不，这是感恩节。是不是因为你的纯蛋白质举重饮食里淀粉太多了？是因为我宁愿烤着吃也不愿吃土豆泥。在我家里，这是个大问题，因为其他人全都喜欢土豆泥。有时我实在忍无可忍，就烤了土豆，结果在晚餐时就成了一场大风波。他们会说，哦，妈妈今晚烤了土豆。这太搞笑了。我完全相反。我是那个超爱土豆泥的人，而我的孩子们却不爱。我就在想，你怎么能不爱土豆泥？这怎么可能？在我看来，关于吃土豆这件事，我们需要交换家庭。
Yeah. Okay. And then everyone's happy. Yeah, I don't know. Jenna, I'm just really disappointed in you right now. Yeah. Shoot. I used to bet they'd be at the bottom. I'd rather have a scalloped. I'd rather have yokey. Last kind of potato I want is mashed. I'm sorry, I said it. Scallop is at the bottom of my list. Really? Yeah. You know, they're fine. I like a scallop potato. And also, my husband makes a thing called a potato stack. So good.
对。好吧，然后大家都开心了。对，我不知道。珍娜，我现在对你真的很失望。对。哎呀。我敢打赌它们会在最底部。我宁愿吃奶油焗土豆。我宁愿吃意式土豆面疙瘩。我最不想吃的土豆就是土豆泥。抱歉，我把话说出来了。奶油焗土豆在我的清单排倒数第一。真的吗？对。你知道，它们其实还行。我挺喜欢奶油焗土豆的。而且，我丈夫会做一种叫土豆塔的东西。超级好吃。
It's like thinly sliced potatoes and then you bake some stuff. Yeah. But I don't know. I'm just always going to go French fry. Yeah, yeah. Same. All right. We didn't know we could talk about this for so long.
就像切得薄薄的土豆片，然后烤一些食材。对。但我不知道。我永远都会选炸薯条。对，对。我也是。好吧。我们压根不知道我们可以聊这个话题聊这么久。
We didn't. We didn't. You were right. Well, listen, why don't we take a break? And then we come back, we will talk with Randall all about the office and other things. Yes. Great. This lady's family, we've got a quick recommendation today that we think you are going to love.
我们真的不知道。你猜得没错。好吧，听着，我们为什么不休息一下？等我们回来，我们将和兰道尔一起聊聊《办公室》以及其他事情。好的。太棒了。各位“办公室女士”的大家庭，今天我们有一个简短的推荐，相信你们一定会喜欢的。
Yes, our friends over at How We Made Your Mother podcast just dropped an incredible episode with the one and only Bob Odenkirk. Yes. And the behind-the-scenes stories that they share in this episode are insane. So first of all, did you know that how I met your mother is accidentally responsible for the creation of a character on Breaking Bad? No, that is crazy. But it's not just TV trivia. Bob also gets really personal. He talks about parenthood. He talks about finding the right amount of fame
对，我们的朋友“老爸老妈浪漫史”播客刚刚发布了一集不可思议的播客，嘉宾是独一无二的鲍勃·奥登科克（Bob Odenkirk）。没错。他们在这集节目中分享的幕后故事简直疯狂。首先，你知道《老爸老妈浪漫史》无意中促成了《绝命毒师》中一个角色的诞生吗？不，这太疯狂了。但这不仅仅是电视冷知识。鲍勃还谈了很多个人私事。他谈到了为人父母。他谈到了如何在名气中找到合适的度
and finding his lane as a dramatic actor, even though he started in comedy. You guys, it is such a funny, insightful, and moving conversation. Head over to your favorite podcast app right now and search for the Bob Odenkirk episode on How We Made Your Mother. You don't want to miss it. So, Randall, we have to ask you a few questions about your time. on the office.
以及如何在转型为戏剧演员后找到自己的方向，尽管他是从喜剧起家的。各位，这真是一场非常有趣、深刻且感人的对话。现在就前往你最喜欢的播客应用，搜索“老爸老妈浪漫史”中的鲍勃·奥登科克那一集吧。你绝对不想错过它。所以，兰道尔，我们必须问你几个关于你在《办公室》里的时光的问题。
My very brief time on the office. But iconic. First of all, how did you get your role on the office? You know, so I was in the last season. Yes. Somewhere towards the end there, the last season. But a few years before that, I auditioned for like a regular role. I was very excited because it's the office.
我非常短暂的《办公室》时光。但却是个标志性的角色。首先，你是如何得到《办公室》里的角色的？你知道的，我当时是在最后一季。没错。接近尾声的时候，也就是最后一季。但在此之前几年，我曾为某个常规角色试镜。我当时非常兴奋，因为那是《办公室》。
And I got a call and it was like, they really like you. They want to meet you. So I went to the studio. and I knew Brent Forrester because I had done a pilot of his years before and he was showing me around and I was just, oh my God, I'm going to be a regular on this show. I met with all the writers, like in a big room, all the writers met with me and I met with Mindy and Daniel and Paul.
我接到一个电话，大意是说：他们真的很喜欢你。他们想见见你。于是我去了工作室。我认识布伦特·福斯特（Brent Forrester），因为我几年前拍过他制作的一部试播集，他当时带着我四处参观，我当时想，天哪，我要成为这部剧的常规演员了。我见到了所有的编剧，在一个大房间里，所有的编剧都跟我见了面，我还见到了敏迪（Mindy）、丹尼尔（Daniel）和保罗（Paul）。
And it was great. And then I went home and I was like, I'm going to be a regular on the office. This is crazy. Oh, no. And then I waited. And then I didn't hear anything. And I was like, it takes time.
那感觉太棒了。然后我回家后心想，我要成为《办公室》的常规演员了。这太疯狂了。哦，不。然后我等待着。接着我什么消息也没听到。我想，这需要时间。
You know, these things take time. You know, they're just getting my trailer ready. You know what I mean? And then I just waited. And it didn't happen. And I was like, oh, my God, what did I say in those meetings? Oh, that's the worst. Yeah.
你知道的，这些事情都需要时间。你知道的，他们只是在帮我准备房车。你知道我的意思吗？然后我就一直等。结果什么都没发生。我当时想，天哪，我在那些会议上到底说了什么？哦，那真是太糟糕了。对。
And then I moved on, you know, started doing other things here and there. And then a couple years later, I just got to call. hey, do you want to come on and play? And I was like, yeah, sure. And I figured, you know, they all knew me at this point. So I didn't audition or anything. They just were like, come on and do this. And then it was just for a cold open.
然后我就继续向前看了，你知道的，开始在这里和那里做其他事情。再然后几年后，我突然接到一个电话：嘿，你想不想来客串一个角色？我想，行啊，没问题。我想象着，你知道的，他们这时候都认识我了。所以我没有去试镜什么的。他们只是说：来演这个吧。结果那只是一场开场戏。
It was really funny. And it was great. And I was like, great, I get to be on the show, even if it's just like a scene. And then it was kind of a whirlwind. It was all very quick. You know, it was very quick. And I was kind of in and out and had a blast. And then that was it.
这真的很有趣。而且感觉很棒。我想，太棒了，我能参演这部剧了，哪怕只是一场戏。然后一切就像一阵旋风。所有事情都发生得非常快。你知道的，非常快。我差不多就是快进快出，玩得超级开心。然后就结束了。
Well, this cold open has gone on to become a fan favorite. Yeah. It is iconic. Should we hear it? We should. It's season nine. The episode is Andy's ancestry. Here it is.
好吧，这场开场戏后来成为了粉丝最爱。没错。这绝对是个经典。我们要听听看吗？我们应该听听。那是第九季。这一集是《安迪的祖先》。就是这里。
Morning, Dwight. Who are you? Who am I? I'm Jim. We've been working together for 12 years. We're a jug, Dwight. You're not Jim. Jim's not Asian.
早安，德怀特。你是谁？我是谁？我是吉姆。我们一起工作12年了。我们是个黄金搭档，德怀特。你不是吉姆。吉姆不是亚洲人。
You serious? Never noticed? Hey, hats off to you for not seeing race. All right then, Jim. Uh, why don't you tell me about that sale that you made yesterday? Uh, Wellington Systems. Sulf them 10 cases of 24 pound letter stock. Or were you talking about Krieger Murphy because I didn't close that one yet, but I'm hoping I've got a voicemail from Paul Krieger waiting for me.
你认真的？从来没注意到？嘿，真佩服你竟然能做到对种族视而不见。好啦，吉姆。呃，你为什么不跟我聊聊你昨天谈成的那笔生意呢？呃，惠灵顿系统公司。卖给他们10箱24磅信纸。或者你是在说克里格·墨菲（Krieger Murphy），因为我还没敲定那单，不过我希望我能收到保罗·克里格（Paul Krieger）留给我的语音留言。
Please enter your password. Oh, and this is when you cover the phone with your hand. Uh-huh. So great. You have one new message. How did you? No, no, no, no. That is sensitive information only for employees, not outsiders. Dwight, cut it out. I'm trying to work.
请输入你的密码。哦，这就是你用手挡住电话的时候。嗯-huh。太棒了。您有一条新留言。你是怎么……不，不，不，不。这是机密信息，只有员工能看，外人不行。德怀特，别闹了。我正忙着工作呢。
You don't work here. You're not Jim. Jim. I got us that dinner reservation. Griko 7.30. Oh, great, can't wait. Jim's at the dentist this morning, and Steve is an actor friend of ours. I don't know who you are, but you are not Jim. This is Jim. And it's you in the picture frame. Yeah.
你才不在这工作呢。你不是吉姆。吉姆。我订好那家餐厅了。格里科餐厅（Griko），7点半。哦，太棒了，等不及了。吉姆今天早上去看牙医了，史蒂夫是我们的一位演员朋友。我不知道你是谁，但你绝对不是吉姆。这就是吉姆。相框里的人才是你。没错。
Oh, dude. How did... And then Dwight's mind melts. Yes. Yes. That was my entire office experience. And for a cold open, Randall, you had a lot of dialogue. Yeah, yeah.
哦，天哪。怎么……然后德怀特的脑子当场烧坏了。没错。没错。这就是我全部的《办公室》体验。而且对于一场开场戏来说，兰道尔，你的台词可真不少。对，对。
You had to just rifle it right off. Like, it was like you had, you know, been working there the whole time. Yeah, yeah. It was kind of like medical drama kind of jargon. There was a lot. Like people's names and all the sale. and all that. Yeah, yeah, it was a lot. But I, you know, at that point, I was well prepared. I think I had some time before the shoot day with the material. And yeah, it was so fun and so surreal.
你必须像机关枪一样把它突突出来。就像是你，你知道的，已经在那里工作了很久一样。对，对。那感觉有点像医疗剧里的行话。台词特别多。比如很多人的名字和所有的销售术语，诸如此类的。对，对，台词量很大。但我，你知道的，那时候我准备得很充分。我觉得在正式拍摄日前我有一段时间来熟悉剧本。是的，这真的超级有趣而且非常超现实。
Just to be acting with you guys on the show that I had loved so much and that I got really close to getting, you know. Well, the writers have shared with us when people would come in that they loved and for whatever reason, you know, they made the character something different. They would have a little folder or they were like people we really liked. That's why they just called you up and said, come do it. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Because they had already fallen in love with you as an actor
能和你们一起在一部我如此喜爱、而且差点就加入的剧中演戏。好吧，编剧们曾跟我们分享过，当有人来试镜且他们非常喜欢时，无论出于什么原因，你知道的，他们把角色改成了别的样子。他们会留存一个小档案，或者觉得这些人真的很棒。这就是为什么他们会直接打电话给你，让你来演。对，对，对。因为他们作为一个演员已经爱上了你
and thought you were in the world of the show. Yeah. I love that that was able to at least come back around in some form. Yeah, yeah. And I was just so happy just to be a part of it, especially the final season, you know, just to like just be on that set and to be able to act with you guys. And yeah, it was such a whirlwind that day
并且觉得你完全契合剧中的世界。对。我很高兴至少能以某种形式再次回归。对，对。我当时只是太高兴能成为其中的一部分了，特别是最后一季，你知道的，能够登上那个片场并和你们一起演戏。真的，那天就像一阵旋风
because, I mean, I think I was only there for a couple hours, you know? And then I remember they whisked me to another room where we took the photo with the kids. And it was very fast. And at that point, you guys were such a well-oiled machine, you know. Yeah. But I kind of, you know, was done in a couple hours. I was like, wow, that was amazing.
因为，我的意思是，我觉得我当时只待了几个小时，你知道的？然后我记得他们把我带到另一个房间，我们和孩子们一起拍了那张照片。一切都非常快。而且到那个时候，你们已经是一台运转极其顺畅的机器了，你知道的。对。但我差不多，你知道的，几个小时就拍完了。我想，哇，这太神奇了。
Did you get to stay for lunch? We had a really good catering. I don't think I did. Oh, no. I'm so sad. You didn't get to have it. Yeah, I don't think I did. Well, something I remember was that we had to kiss.
你有留下来吃午饭吗？我们的剧组餐饮真的很好。我觉得我没有。哦，不。我太难过了。你没能吃到。对，我觉得我没有。好吧，我记得的一件事是，我们必须接吻。
Yes, yes, yes. I was going to ask you guys about that. And we were, I remember laughing with you about it. We're like, well, hello. Yeah. And hi. And also, we usually film those cold opens first thing in the morning. I don't know if that's your memory, if it was like an early call time.
对，对，对。我正想问你们这件事呢。而且我记得当时我还和你们一起笑着谈论这个。我们当时的想法是，噢，你好。对。还有嗨。而且，我们通常会在一早第一件事就拍摄那些开场戏。我不知道你们的记忆是不是这样，是不是通告时间非常早。
I believe so. It was first half of the day, for sure. So you guys are like, good morning. How are you? Nice to meet you. Let's kiss. Yeah. A little bit.
我想是的。绝对是前半天拍的。所以你们的状态就像是，早安。你好吗？很高兴认识你。我们来接吻吧。对。稍微亲一下。
Yeah. And of course, you know, whenever you have to kiss someone, it's always like just adds to the nerves a little bit, even though it's just acting. It's still like, oh, my God. And it wasn't like this. crazy spooch or anything, but it's like a very intimate thing to do. Yeah. To just put your lips on someone else's lips within like four minutes of meeting them. A little bit. Yeah. And I remember, of course, being nervous about that, but not saying anything. Just do it, be professional.
对。当然了，你知道的，每当你要和某人接吻时，总是会让人稍微感到有些紧张，尽管这只是演戏。那种感觉依然像是，哦，天哪。而且那可不是什么疯狂的法式舌吻，但那仍然是一件非常私密的事情。对。在见面大约四分钟内就把你的嘴唇贴到另一个人的嘴唇上。有点像。对。我记得，当然了，我当时对此感到紧张，但什么也没说。只管演就是了，要专业。
Professional. But it's always like, oh my gosh, this is like this job is so crazy. So crazy. And even something as simple as that, I even remember being nervous too, because I'm standing up and I have to kind of like hunch around to get to you. And I'm like, God, just don't like, accidentally kiss his eye or like part of his cheek. Like just landed. It was a walking kiss. It was. It was like a drive-by kiss.
专业。但那种感觉总是像，哦天哪，这工作太疯狂了。简直太疯狂了。甚至连这么简单的一件事，我当时也记得自己很紧张，因为我站着，而且我必须有点驼着背才能够到你。我当时想，上帝啊，千万别，不小心亲到她的眼睛或者脸颊的一部分。一定要精准命中。那是一个边走边亲的吻。确实是的。那就像是一个“路过式”的吻。
Yeah. Exactly. If you think about the world of the show too, Pam has kissed Roy. Yep. Jim. Mm-hmm. And Steve.
没错。如果你回想一下这部剧的世界，帕姆亲过罗伊。没错。吉姆。嗯-hmm。还有史蒂夫。
But everybody calls you Agent Jim. Yeah. Yeah. I think that's what it's like credited as. Is it? I think so. No. Oh my gosh.
但每个人都叫你“亚洲吉姆”。对。对。我想演职员表里就是这么写的。是吗？我想是的。没有。哦，天哪。
I'd have to look. I think so. script, your character's name is Steve. Yeah, in the script. I feel like I need to check on IMDB. Yeah. You are credited as Asian Jim Halpert. Oh my gosh.
我得去查查。我想是的。剧本里，你角色的名字是史蒂夫。对，剧本里是这样。我觉得我得去IMDB上确认一下。对。你演职员表里写的是“亚洲吉姆·哈珀特”。哦，天哪。
Yes. Yes, that's, that is true. That's crazy. Yeah, yeah. And I think, gosh, I should track down those scripts. I'm bringing up the script right now. Oh, you are. Wait for it.
是的。是的，那是真的。太疯狂了。对，对。而且我觉得，天哪，我应该把那些剧本找出来。我现在就把剧本调出来。哦，你正在调。拭目以待吧。
Okay. Cold open, Dwight is at his desk. A 30-something guy who looks sort of like an Asian version of Jim approaches. In the script, your name is Asian guy. And then Pam in the script calls you Steve. Oh, okay, okay. Okay. Yeah. But you have all that dialogue about that I'm hoping for a voicemail from Paul. Krieger Murphy. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah. Oh, yeah. They kiss. Pam walks off. Amazing. Amazing. Amazing. Do you get recognized from being on the office? How is that plagued? Do you? Because people shout random things at us.
好的。开场戏，德怀特坐在他的办公桌前。一个30多岁、看起来有点像吉姆的亚洲版的男子走了过来。在剧本里，你的名字是“亚洲男子”。然后剧本里的帕姆叫你史蒂夫。哦，好吧，好吧。好吧。对。但你有一大堆台词，关于我正在等保罗的语音留言。克里格·墨菲。对，对，对。对，没错。他们亲吻了。帕姆走开了。太神奇了。太神奇了。太神奇了。你走在街上会被认出是《办公室》里的演员吗？大家对此有何反应？因为人们总是对我们大喊各种随机的话。
Like someone has shouted to me, green is horrish. I had on a green tank top. And I was like, what? And then I'm like, oh, right. Yeah. Well, you know, I mean, it was after I filmed it and even after it aired, I didn't get recognized too much from it. But eventually, I would say several years later is when it became like a meme.
比如有人曾对我大喊：绿色真恶心。我当时穿着一件绿色的背心。我心想，什么？然后我才反应过来，哦，对了。对。好吧，你知道的，在我拍完之后，甚至在它播出之后，我并没有因为这个而被太多人认出来。但最终，可以说是在好几年后，它才变成了一个梗
and when it started really circulating online. And that's when, yeah, people would. I think I was talking about it on Conan once. You know, I had kind of forgotten about it. Not forgotten about it, but it just wasn't top of mind. Sure. It was a long time ago. And somebody screamed out,
并在网络上真正开始广为流传。从那以后，是的，人们就会……我想我曾在柯南（Conan）的节目里谈到过它。你知道的，我其实已经有点把它给忘了。也不是忘了，就是它没怎么占据我的脑海。当然。那是很久以前的事了。然后有人大喊：
Hey, Asian Jim. And I like turned around and I thought it was like some like racial thing. Or I didn't know, you know, because I just didn't put it together. And then soon enough, yeah, I'd hear more. or Asian gyms. And I go, okay, okay. It's online. Yeah. It's online. And now also, in some small way, you guys brought it back because you did this thing with John Cresensky for the trailer, for his movie, right? Yes, for it. That was so funny. How did you even do it? You're like pranking Ryan Reynolds because you're saying you are John Crosinski. And it kind of broke the internet. People like went
嘿，亚洲吉姆！我当时猛地转过身，心想这不会是什么种族歧视吧。或者我不知道，你知道的，因为我根本没把这两者联系起来。不过很快，是的，我就会听到更多。或者“亚洲吉姆们”。然后我就想，好吧，好吧。它在网上火了。对。它在网上火了。而且现在，在某种程度上，你们又把它带回了现实，因为你和约翰·卡拉辛斯基（John Krasinski）一起为他的电影预告片拍了那个短片，对吧？是的，为了那个。那太搞笑了。你们到底是怎么做到的？你就像是在恶作剧瑞安·雷诺兹（Ryan Reynolds），因为你宣称自己是约翰·卡拉辛斯基。这简直快把互联网给玩瘫痪了。人们简直
berserk for it. I mean, I think it was such a big thing online for so many years. years and John was directing that movie and I don't know if it was Ryan or John I think it might have been Ryan who thought who came up with it and asked if I'd be down to to do it like yeah of course yeah but you had to change your clothes like multiple times to be inserted into like scenes of you directing the movie yes yeah that's right that's right it's really I just shot on a green screen in different outfits and they just kind of somehow put me in there indie shots, BTS shots that they had made for the movie.
疯狂了。我的意思是，我觉得它在网络上作为大热梗已经存在很多年了。约翰当时在导演那部电影，我不知道是瑞安还是约翰——我觉得可能是瑞安想出的这个主意，并问我愿不愿意参与——我说，好啊，当然愿意。但你必须换很多次衣服，以便被剪辑进你导演电影的各种场景里。是的，没错，没错。这真的很……我只是穿着不同的服装在绿幕前拍摄，然后他们不知怎么就把我塞进了那些他们为电影拍摄的室内镜头、幕后花絮镜头里。
It was crazy. It was fun. It was very fun. But yeah, I mean, it just speaks to the power of the internet. It was just such a big thing. Yeah.
这太疯狂了。很有趣。真的非常有趣。但，我的意思是，这正好说明了互联网的力量。这真是一个巨大的热梗。对。
Yeah. Yeah. And to this day, people like, it's funny because it was such a big thing online that some people come up to me thinking that I was a regular on the show, you know,
对，对。直到今天，人们依然……很有趣的是，因为它在网上的热度太高了，以至于有些人走过来对我说，以为我是剧中的常规演员，你知道的
even though I wasn't. You know, it was just one scene. You know? But you stole the scene, you know? I mean, that's all you can ever hope
尽管我并不是。你知道的，我其实只演了一场戏。你知道吗？但你抢尽了风头，你知道吗？我的意思是，无论你的角色有多大或多小，这都是你唯一能期望的事情。就像如果你抓住了那个高光时刻，你会觉得：我把这场戏完美拿下了。对。对我来说，在拍摄当天，我的想法其实就是：能参与其中我真的太开心了。我太高兴能来到片场，尤其是来到这个特定的片场。那是一种“好吧，这太棒了。这太棒了。下一个是什么”的心态。对。嗯，我们在《初来乍到》（Fresh Off the Boat）里再次合作了。没错。你表现得太棒了。对，你演了好几集。我演了。我饰演杰西卡（Jessica，由吴恬敏饰）死对头。她的死对头。对。她真的，又是一个刻薄鬼。我这算不算被类型化了。但那真的超级好玩。那里的每个人都超级好。
for no matter like how big or small your role. Like if you get that moment or you're like, I just owned that. Yeah. I mean, for me literally on the day, it was just like, I'm just so happy to be a part of this. I'm just so happy to be on set, on this set in particular. And it was one of those like, okay, that was great. That was great. What's the next? Yeah. Well, we were united after office on Fresh Off the Boat. That's right. You were so great. Yeah, you did several episodes. I did. I played Jessica, who's played by Constance Wu, like her nemesis. Her nemesis. Yeah. She's such, again, a bitch. My didn't typecasting. But that was super fun. And everybody there was so nice.
而且那部剧播了大约六年吧？六季。对。在ABC电视台播得很好。非常棒。超级好玩。而且，是的，你能来客串真的太棒了。对，我当时简直不敢相信你会来演。因为，再次说明，我是《办公室》的超级大粉丝。所以，是的，这感觉太酷了。我其实很希望我们这两对夫妻，我希望我们能有更多类似双人约会的戏份，因为那些晚餐戏真的很有趣。对。
And that was on for like six years, right? Six seasons. Yeah. That was great on ABC. It was great. It was super fun. And yeah, it was so great having you on. Yeah, I was just tripping that you were on the show. Because, again, I was such a huge fan at the office. And yeah, it was. It was very cool. I was really hoping that our two couples, I was hoping we had some more like double dates because that was really, those like dinner scenes were fun. Yeah.
不过我和珍娜最近一直在回顾你的电影作品，看各种各样的作品，我们真的是你的超级粉丝。我有一件事想聊，你也有你想聊的事情。但我先来。你可以先来。好的。昨天晚上，我和我的青少年孩子们一起看了一部电影，因为我们的制作人马特·比格尔（Matt Beagle）曾对我们说：如果你们喜欢浪漫喜剧，你们一定要看
But Jenna and I have both just sort of been going over your filmography and watching all kinds stuff and we're such fans of yours. And I have something I want to talk about and you have something you want to talk about. But I want to go first. You can go first. Okay. So last night with my teenagers, we watch, because our producer Matt Beagle was like, if you guys love rom-coms. You have to see
你们演的《兜风》（Always Be My Maybe）。他今天不能来，他让我们转告你，这是他最喜欢的浪漫喜剧。天哪。所以我当时想，我超爱浪漫喜剧。我怎么会错过那部呢？我一定要看。真的太好看了。你在里面太搞笑了。里面有好多有趣的人，而且你知道的，黄阿丽（Ali Wong）太棒了。
Always Be My Maybe that you did. He couldn't be here today and he wanted us to tell you it's his favorite rom-com. Oh my God. So I was like, I love a rom-com. I don't know how I miss that one. I want to watch it. It's so good. You're so funny in it. There's so many funny people in this and you know, Ali Wong is great.
但对于那些长期收听《办公室女士》的听众来说，你们知道珍娜和我对基努·里维斯（Keanu Reeves）有着轻微的痴迷。而你在片中和基努·里维斯有一场超级搞笑的对手戏，你狠狠地揍了他的脸。我打了他的脸。我真的打了。我确信你已经谈过很多次了，
But for those of you who have listened to Office Ladies for a long time, you know that Jen and I are slightly obsessed with Keanu Reeves. And you have a hilarious scene with Keanu Reeves and you punch him in the face. I punch him in the face. I do. I'm sure you've talked about this a lot,
但求求你了，能跟我们讲讲拍那些对手戏的幕后花絮以及当时是什么感觉吗？你在里面太逗了，你对他简直恨之入骨。那又是一次超现实的体验。我的意思是，你知道的，正如你们所知道的那样，这份工作充满了超现实的经历。我们应该说明一下，基努在片中饰演他自己，对吧？
but please can you tell us everything about being in scenes and what was that like? And you're so funny in it, and you get so pissed off at him. That was another surreal. I mean, you know, this job is just filled with surreal experiences, as you guys know. We should say Keanu plays himself, right?
是的，是的。而且他和你的梦中情人去约会了。你不得不看着你爱的人和基努·里维斯约会。对，我们在进行一次双人约会。对，双人约会。不过两个女人都对基努·里维斯爱得死去活来。从某种程度上来说这很真实，对吧？对，整个项目都超级好玩，因为我有机会和我的老朋友阿丽合作。
Yes, yes. And he goes out on a date with the person that you're in love with. You have to like watch the person you love be on a date with Keanu Reeves. Yeah, we're on a double date. Yeah, on a double date. And both of the women, though, are just like in love with Keanu Reeves. It's pretty real in that way, right? Yeah, that whole project was so fun because I got to work with Ali, who's an old friend.
我们当时想要一个明星客串，你知道的，一个扮演自己的名人。我想我们列了一份我们觉得能请得动的演员名单。他们全都是我们喜爱的人，名气远没有基努·里维斯那么大。我们把那份名单交给了网飞（Netflix）。网飞的反应是：你们为什么不做个更大的梦呢？你知道的？比如谁才是理想人选？对。我们的回答是：基努·里维斯就是理想人选。
And we wanted a celebrity cameo, you know, celebrity to play himself. And I believe we had a list of just like people who we thought we could get, you know. And they were all like people we loved, not nearly as famous as Keanu Reeves. And we presented that list to Netflix. And Netflix was like, why don't you like dream bigger, you know? Like who's the ideal? Yeah. And we were like, Keanu Reeves is the ideal.
他们的反应是：那就朝着这个目标试试吧。我们不知怎么真的把他请到了。他当时正在拍摄《疾速追杀》（John Wick），但他正好有空档。而且他非常喜欢在这部浪漫喜剧中扮演他自己的这个主意。他在湾区（Bay Area）待了几天。他真的是人超级好。他是那种极其温和的人。我的意思是，所有的传闻都是真的，你知道的。
They were like, let's try for that. And we somehow got him. He was like shooting John Wick at the time, but he had an opening. And he loved the idea of playing himself in this, you know, rom-com. And he came out for a few days in the Bay Area. And he was just so incredibly nice. He's just like so kind. I mean, all the stories, you know.
难道这不是你最想听到的吗？是的。萨姆，你现在是不是幸福得要飞起了？我太激动了。对，他真的超级善良，超级开朗，跟我们分享了那么多他的人生经历和故事。而且在拍戏时超级配合，你知道的。总是能当场即兴发挥。有一个镜头是他戴着眼镜，然后他把眼镜摘了下来。
Isn't everything you want to hear? Yes. Sam, are you so happy right now? I'm thrilled. Yeah, he was so kind, so open, just sharing so much of his life and his stories with us. And so game, you know, in the scenes. Just coming up with pitches. There's a moment where he's wearing glasses and he takes them off.
我把手指直接穿过了镜框。我说：这眼镜里根本没有镜片啊。他回答说：我知道。这其实就是他的即兴点子，你知道的。他当时有很多这种即兴点子。是的，真的超级有趣又超现实。而且我们当时在拍夜戏。所以感觉有点像，你知道的，拍夜戏压力其实很大。
And I put my fingers through the cloud. I'm like, there's no lenses in these glasses. And he's like, I know. And that was like his pitch, you know. He had a bunch of pitches like that. And yeah, it was just so fun and surreal. And we were doing overnights. So it was kind of like, you know, it's stressful to do overnights.
但他真的非常专业，你知道的。随时准备配合。随时配合。对。我必须再读一段。里面有一首你唱说唱的歌，叫做《我打了基努·里维斯》（I Punched Keanu Reeves）。这绝对是其中最棒的歌词之一。你唱道：最好相信我打了基努，那感觉比你在《生死时速》里看到的任何场面都要爽。我打了约翰·维克，现在我感觉帅呆了。你唱得可比我刚才念的好听多了。你知道的，那是……所以我的角色在电影里有一个乐队，这个乐队有点像我大学时加入过的一个乐队。在我们在拍完这部电影并剪辑好之后，有人提出了一个建议：为什么不在片尾字幕播放一首歌，歌词内容就是你角色在痛扁基努·里维斯之后的心情呢？于是我们把它录了下来，并放到了片尾字幕里。是的，效果太棒了。
But he was just so professional, you know. So like just down to play. Down to play. Yeah. I do have to read one more thing. There is a song that you rap called I Punched Keanu Reeves. And this is like one of the best lyrics. You say, best believe I punched Keanu.
我对这个爆料有一个后续问题，那就是你在乐队里负责什么？你是乐队的主唱吗？你弹吉他吗？你负责什么？在大学乐队里吗？它有点像是一个嘻哈乐队。我是两位主唱之一。对，对，对。
And it was better than any scene you could see in speed. I hit John Wick and now I'm feeling so appealing. You do it so much better than I just read it. You know, that was, so my character is in a band in the movie that was kind of based on this band that I was in out of college. And that after we shot the film, edited it, somebody had pitched like, why don't we like to the closing credits to a song that your character made like, like after punching canneries. So we recorded it and we put it in the closing credits. And yeah, it was great.
你们大学乐队叫什么名字？叫“再次生病”（Ill Again）。再次生病。对。对。你现在还做音乐吗？不。不，只为电影创作。
I have a follow-up question to that nugget, which is what did you do in the band? Are you in the front band? Do you play guitar? What do you do? In the college band? It was kind of like a hip-hop band. And I was one of two frontmen. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
只为了那部电影。好吧。还有在家里。在浴室里。好吧。对。好吧。几个月前，我在随便刷着找点东西看。
What was the name of your college band? It was called Ill Again. Ill again. Yeah. Yeah. And do you make music anymore? No. No, just for the movies.
你大学乐队的名字叫什么？叫做Ill Again。Ill again。是啊。是啊。你现在还做音乐吗？不做了。不做了，只为电影做。
It's just for that movie. Okay. And around the house. In the shower. Okay. Yeah. Okay. Well, a couple of months ago, I was scrolling for something to watch.
就为那部电影。好的。还有在家里。在淋浴时。好的。是啊。好吧。几个月前，我在刷剧找东西看。
I'm on Netflix. And this show called The Residence Pops up, which I was not familiar with, but which I am now obsessed. She's obsessed. And now I have to shut up about it. It's great. Okay. I'm going to watch it. It is such a great limited series.
我打开了奈飞。然后弹出了一个叫《白宫u来谋杀》的节目，以前我没看、过，但现在我迷上了。她迷上了。现在我得闭嘴不谈了。这太棒了。好吧。我要去看。这真是一部出色的限定剧。
I have not finished it, so I do not know the ending, but you are in it and it is fantastic. And I just want to throw it out there to everybody. I mean, this is one of those we always say late to the party. Like, welcome, Jenna, late to the party. People were nominated for awards. But what was it like making that show? Like, as a fan of that show, I just want to hear, like, how did, it was so cool. The camera work and all of it.
我还没看完，所以我不知道结局，但你在里面，太棒了。我只想把它推荐给大家。我的意思是，这就是我们总是说的后知后觉。就像，欢迎啊，珍娜，后知后觉。人们都获得奖项提名了。但制作那部剧是什么感觉？作为一个那部剧的粉丝，我只是想听听，是怎么样的，太酷了。摄影运镜以及所有这些。
All the levels. And it takes place at the White House. At the White House. Yeah, and it's a murder mystery. Yes, you play an FBI detective. Yeah, who's partnered with Uzo Aduba. Oh, she's great. Yeah, she's amazing.
所有的层面。而且故事发生在白宫。在白宫。对，这是一个谋杀悬疑故事。没错，你饰演一个FBI侦探。对，和乌佐·阿杜巴搭档。哦，她很棒。对，她太棒了。
She's the best. I play tennis with her. I know that's random, but at the International Tennis Hall of Fame, we play tennis. Really? Yeah, okay, sorry, sorry. Yeah, she's the best. And, yeah, we shot it like not too far from here, right down the street from here. And it was one of the best experiences, but also, like, a tough experience because it was, you know, we were shooting, and then the strike happened.
她是最好的。我和她打网球。我知道这听起来很随机，但在国际网球名人堂，我们打网球。真的吗？对，好吧，抱歉，抱歉。对，她是最棒的。而且，我们在离这不远的地方拍的，就在离这儿一个街区的地方。这是最棒的经历之一，但同时也是一次艰难的经历，因为你知道的，我们正在拍摄，然后罢工发生了。
Yeah, during the shoot. And then one of our cast members was Andre Brower, who passed during the shoot. And that was very difficult for all of us. And also just for the show. So there were a lot of, it was a very not tumultuous experience, but there were a lot of, you know, kind of heavy challenges. Yeah. Yeah.
对，在拍摄期间。然后我们的一个演员是安德鲁·布劳尔，他在拍摄期间去世了。这让我们所有人都非常难过。对这部剧来说也是如此。所以有很多，这并不是说是一段混乱的经历，但有很多，你知道的，相当沉重的挑战。是的。对。
Yeah, that we got through. And the show turned out great. We're just so proud of it. And we're all like so close. I think because we bonded so tight over the, you know, all the things that happened during that. But yeah, I'm so glad you enjoyed the show. It's really special.
是的，我们挺过来了。这部剧效果很好。我们为它感到骄傲。我们大家都非常亲密。我想是因为我们在，你知道的，经历的所有事情中建立了非常深厚的感情。但是，是的，我很高兴你喜欢这部剧。它真的很特别。
Yeah, it is. It's special. Yeah. And I love hearing how close you guys are. Yeah. You feel it. Yeah. And there's a quickness to the comedy.
是的，确实如此。很特别。是的。而且我很高兴听到你们关系这么好。是的。你能感觉得到。是的。而且喜剧的节奏很快。
There's a lot of timing in the show. But then there's also this very riveting mystery. Yeah. It's very intricate. And that's one of those shows where it was kind of like word for word. Like you do it as written. Do not stray from the script. if you get one word wrong
剧里有很多对白时机。但同时也有非常引人入胜的悬疑。对。非常复杂。而且那是那种几乎是一字不差的剧本。就像你必须按写好的来演。绝不能偏离剧本。如果你错了一个字
and then the script supervise will come and oh this is that you got that one word wrong. Because you're building so much together you can't like go off too much. It's just so intricate and the timing of it
然后剧本总监就会过来，哦，这个，你那个字说错了。因为你们一起构建了这么多内容，所以你不能偏离太多。它太复杂了，而且对白的时机
was just so important and we also just wanted to honor the writer, you know, Paul William Davies and just make sure that you know we just did it just right you know. I mean I've done that a few times
太重要了，而且我们也只想向编剧致敬，你知道的，保罗·威廉·戴维斯，并确保我们，你知道的，把它演得恰到好处。我的意思是，我有过几次这样的经历
on different shows where they're just like this is word for word and that's always like oh okay, okay. That's challenging. But on this one, it was actually quite easy because the writing was just so kind of lyrical and rhythmic and bouncing off of these great actors like Uzo. It just kind of became like very, I don't know, it's almost like making music.
在不同的剧组里，他们会说，这个必须逐字逐句来，那种时候总是会觉得，哦，好吧，好吧。这很有挑战性。但在这部剧里，实际上相当容易，因为台词非常富有诗意和韵律感，而且和乌佐这样的优秀演员对戏时，那种感觉就变得非常，怎么说呢，几乎就像在创作音乐。
Yeah. Yeah, it's fun. Well, I love it. Jenna actually told me, you know how there's shows or movies or music you listen to that you then need like your best friend to listen to or watch so you can discuss this morning. She was like, I'm going to need you to watch. much. I was like, okay, okay. It's true.
对。是的，这很有趣。我太喜欢了。珍娜甚至告诉我，你知道有些节目、电影或音乐，你听了之后需要你的闺蜜也去听或看，这样你们就能讨论了。今天早上她说，我需要你看。我说，好吧，好吧。这是真的。
But you've also had roles in the audacity, which just got renewed for a second season. Yeah, yeah. Can you talk about that? It's a really great show on the AMC, about characters in Silicon Valley, but very different from Silicon Valley, the show. Really funny, really kind of dark and scary, you know.
但你还在《无畏》中演过角色，这部剧刚刚续订了第二季。对，对。你能聊聊这个吗？AMC上的一部非常棒的剧，讲的是硅谷里的人物，但和电视剧《硅谷》很不一样。非常有趣，有点黑暗和吓人，你知道的。
And I play this kind of tech mogul who's since kind of retreated from the world then coming back again for the next season because it got ordered for another season. That's great. Yeah, Zach Alfenakis is in it, Billy Magnuson. It's just a killer cast and a really, really fun watch. Well, that's on our list. And also, I have to say, my sons loved Wanda Vision.
我饰演的是一个科技大亨，之前有点隐退于世，然后因为续订了另一季，在下一季中又回归了。太棒了。对，扎克·加利凡纳基斯参演了，比利·马格努森也演了。演员阵容非常强大，而且真的非常非常好看。好吧，这在我们的愿望单上。而且，我必须说，我的儿子们非常喜欢《旺达幻视》。
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. And I know, Sam, you have a question. Yes, I do. Jimmy Wu's my favorite character. No joke, in the MCU, the ending of Ant Man, the exchange where you're like, I thought you were inviting me somewhere. is my favorite moment from any Marvel movie.
哦，对，对，对。我知道，山姆，你有一个问题。是的，我有。吉米·乌是我最喜欢的角色。说真的，在漫威宇宙里，《蚁人》结局时，你那句“我还以为你是邀请我去什么地方呢”的对话
My question was if you had any plans to revive that character in anything coming up. Nothing, for sure. There are some things that may happen, but we'll see. Good, good, good. But we'll see, but it's kind of, you know. I'm sure you're not even allowed to say. Yeah, yeah. And they may not.
是我在任何漫威电影中最喜欢的时刻。我的问题是，你有没有计划在接下来的什么作品中让这个角色复活。没有，绝对没有。有些事情可能会发生，但我们走着瞧。很好，很好，很好。不过我们走着瞧，但这有点，你知道的。我敢肯定你甚至都不被允许说。对，对。而且他们可能也不会。
Let's just put it out there. All right. It's coming back. But yeah, it's being in the Marvel kind of world. It's just such a, again, all of these experiences. where it's just like... Well, while I have you, I realized this morning, I saw you about 10 years ago, speaking of surreal moments,
我们把它说出来吧。好吧。它会回来的。但是，是的，身处漫威的世界里。这真的是一个，再次说明，所有这些经历。就好像……好吧，趁我还抓得到你，我今天早上意识到，大约10年前我见过你，说到超现实的时刻，
right down the street at the Montalban Theater, you did a live stage reading of this script called Saving Charlie Chaplin. Oh, yeah. And my question for you was, I remember distinctly you're on stage between John Hamm and Paul Rubens, who's my hero. Yeah. What was that like getting to do a live stage reading with pee-wee?
就在蒙塔尔班剧院那条街上，你现场朗读了一个叫《拯救查理·卓别林》的剧本。哦，是的。我问你的问题是，我清楚地记得你站在乔恩·哈姆和保罗·雷宾斯之间，他是我的偶像。是的。和皮威一起现场朗读是什么感觉？
I mean, come on. It's pee-wee. Yeah, right? Yeah. That was, gosh, I forgot about that. Yeah. That was really fun. And it's one of those kind of you look around and you see these people that you're on stage with and it's another kind of surreal thing. Okay. Excellent. Yeah, it was very surreal. And I love doing stuff like that. You know, like if I get invited to take part in a read of something or any kind of opportunity to kind of, you know, you just meet people. You meet people and it's always fun. And sometimes you meet your heroes. Yeah. Yeah. Great.
我的天哪。那是皮威。对吧？对啊。那是，天哪，我都忘了。那真的很有趣。那种感觉就是你环顾四周，看到和你同台的这些人，这是又一种超现实的事情。好吧。太棒了。是的，非常超现实。而且我很喜欢做那种事。你知道的，如果我被邀请去参加某个剧本朗读，或者任何有机会去，你知道的，你就是会结识人。你会结识各种各样的人，总是很有趣。有时你甚至能见到你的偶像。对。对。太棒了。
It's so fun to have those creative bursts that you're not expecting. you know, and run-ins with people and what that brings out of you. And you've worked for so long, you've done so many amazing roles. What was the very first job you got in entertainment? Well, the real first one I got, I was in college at UCLA. And I thought to myself, I think I would love to be an actor one day. And I didn't end up pursuing acting until way after college. But at the time, I started auditioning for like things that I would find in the back of backstage West.
拥有那种意料之外的创作爆发力真的很有趣，你知道的，跟人们的不期而遇以及这能激发你怎样的潜能。你入行很久了，演过那么多精彩的角色。你进入娱乐圈得到的第一份工作是什么？嗯，我得到的真正第一份工作，我当时还在加州大学洛杉矶分校上大学。我心想，有一天我大概很想成为一名演员。直到大学毕业很久之后，我才真正开始追求演艺事业。但当时，我开始试镜一些我在《西方后台》杂志背面看到的东西。
Does that still exist backstage? I don't know. Does it exist digitally? I don't even know. I'd still like it probably does online, right? But not we would go get the paper and flip to the back and circle things. Yeah, circle the casting announcements and the student films and kind of anything. And I auditioned for a commercial.
那个杂志现在还存在吗？后台杂志？我不知道。它有数字版的吗？我甚至都不知道。我猜它大概网上还有吧，对吧？但以前不是这样的，我们会去买纸质版，翻到后面圈出一些东西。对，圈出选角通告和学生电影以及各种类似的机会。我去试镜了一个广告。
It was a non-union commercial that was going to appear on the Channel 18 in L.A., which is kind of like the Asian channel at the time. They would have like the Cantonese language stuff. And then later that night, they would have, you know, stuff in Mandarin and Korean, you know. And I booked it. And it was basically a commercial for these liver pills. Oh, my goodness. How old were you?
那是一个非工会广告，将在洛杉矶的18频道播出，当时那个频道有点像亚视频道。他们会播放粤语节目。然后那天晚上的晚些时候，你知道的，他们会播放普通话和韩语的节目，你知道的。然后我拿到了这个角色。基本上这是一个关于保肝药的广告。哦，天哪。你当时多大？
I was in college. They were for these liver pills and I played a dad. The whole thing was in voiceover in Mandarin. So I didn't understand what I was selling, really. And I come in and I'm like super tired from. from work and my kid runs up and he wants to play, but I'm too tired. And then the kid, like, it's like, oh my gosh, liver pills. And then he runs to the cabinet, pulls out these liver pills and hands him to me. My 19 year old dad. Yeah. And then I was suddenly like full of energy.
我还在上大学。那是关于这些保肝药的，我扮演一个父亲。整个广告都是普通话配音。所以我其实并不明白我在卖什么。我走进去，表现得工作非常累。然后我的孩子跑过来想玩，但我太累了。然后那个孩子，就像是，哦天哪，保肝药。然后他跑到橱柜前，掏出这些保肝药递给我。我这个19岁的父亲。对。然后我突然间就充满了活力。
And that was like my first thing. And I, you know, at the time, I was like, oh my God, this is going to change my life. This is my entry into Hollywood, you know. Did you have a copy of this anywhere? I do. I do. That is amazing. I'm really. bad in it. I'm like so overacting everything. But yeah, that was my first, very first thing that got, you know, a modicum of airplay, I guess. And some of my friends' parents saw it. They were like, wait, you're the liver pill dad. Yeah. And I was like, yep, that's me. That's me. Swagger, swagger. So what were you studying in school? Were you studying? I was studying. I was an English major. There was a creative writing specialization.
这就是我的第一份工作。当时我想，天哪，这会改变我的人生。这是我进入好莱坞的敲门砖，你知道的。你有留着这份东西的备份吗？我有。我有。太惊人了。我演得真烂。我把所有东西都演得太夸张了。不过，是的，这是我的第一件，真正获得了一定程度曝光的作品，我想。我的一些朋友的父母看到了。他们说，等等，你就是那个保肝药爸爸。对。然后我说，对，那就是我。那就是我。神气活现的。那么你在学校主修什么？你当时在学习吗？我在学习。我主修英语。有一个创意写作专业方向。
And so I was basically majoring in kind of short fiction writing. Okay. And then I minored in Asian American Studies. And so, yeah. So later, when you decide to become an actor and take that seriously, is there a role or an experience that you consider to be your big break? Yeah, you know, I think for me, I could really sense like a change in just what was incoming when I did VEP.
所以我基本上主修的是短篇小说写作。好的。然后我辅修了亚裔美国人研究。所以，是的。后来当你决定成为一名演员并认真对待这件事时，有没有哪个角色或经历被你认为是你的重大突破？是的，你知道的，我觉得对我来说，当我参演《副总统》时，我真的能感觉到周围风向的变化。
Oh, yeah. Yeah. That was a real kind of like, okay, things are different now. And I think because the show was so good and people loved it, it was so well respected in the industry especially
哦，对。是的。那真是一种“好吧，现在情况不同了”的感觉。而且我想因为这部剧太棒了，人们都很喜欢它，它在行业内受到了极大的尊重，尤其是
that when I was, yeah, doing VEP, that's when things started to come to me. Yeah. And that was after, I believe I did the office. And fresh off the boat came from that and a lot of things kind of came from that. Yeah.
当我，是的，在拍《副总统》的时候，机会就是那个时候开始主动找上门来的。是的。那是在我拍完《办公室》之后，我相信是的。然后《初来乍到》也是从那之后接到的，很多机会都是从那之后开始出现的。是的。
Such a great. show. So critically acclaimed. Yeah. It just elevated probably everything. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I really could sense like, oh, wow, people like watch in the industry, especially watch the show and love it. And yeah, that's when like things just started changing. Have you ever written a character for yourself? You know, you are a creative writing major. Yeah. I mean, always be my maybe. Allie and I wrote that along with another writer friend, Michael Anko. And that was so fun. Because I was. I put in so much of my own life into that, including the band that I was in, stuff like that. Yeah. So that was my first taste of that, and I've been doing more of that lately.
真是一部伟大的剧。备受好评。是的。它可能提升了一切。是的。是的。是的。是的，我真的能感觉到，哦，天哪，业内的人，尤其是业内的人都在看这部剧并且非常喜欢它。然后，是的，事情就是从那个时候开始改变的。你有没有为自己写过一个角色？你知道的，你可是创意写作专业出身。是的。我是说，《别担心我》。我和另一个作家朋友迈克尔·安科一起写了《别担心我》。那太有趣了。因为我。我把自己生活中的很多东西都放进去了，包括我曾经呆过的乐队，诸如此类的东西。是的。所以这是我初次尝到甜头，最近我一直在做更多这方面的事情。
Would you ever write something for you to do on stage like that? I've been thinking about that. Yeah. I've been thinking about that. Because when I was in college, my initial kind of introduction to acting started out in playwriting. There was this college theater company that I had co-founded with some friends and we wrote our own original plays and that was like kind of my way in, you know, in terms of just like discovering my love for performing. So yeah, I would love to one day. Yeah. Yeah, I did a long time ago, I wrote a one woman show and I wrote all these different characters and I look back on it now and I'm like, oh, they were so, I don't know. Was this like pre the office? Pre everything and I wrote this one woman show, but I got it, you know,
你会不会为自己写一些像这样的舞台表演作品？我一直在考虑这个。是的。我一直在考虑这个。因为当我上大学时，我最初接触表演是从剧本创作开始的。我和一些朋友共同创立了一个大学剧团，我们创作了自己的原创戏剧，这基本上算是我入行的方式，你知道的，就如同发现了自己对表演的热爱一样。所以，是的，我希望有一天能尝试。是的。是的，很久以前，我写过一个独角戏，我写了所有这些不同的角色，现在回想起来，我心想，哦，她们太，怎么说呢。这是在《办公室》之前吗？在一切之前，我写了这个独角戏，但我拿到了，你知道的，
some people came to it and I got a manager out of it and I got a little review and all that stuff. But I've always wondered like what it would be like to revisit those characters. Oh, you totally sure. Yeah. And like 30 years later. Oh, my God, I'm so old. But yeah, Jenna loves theater so much and my daughter does. And I love theater too, but I feel like I've become more patient in a way and how I take like entertainment into my life.
有些人来看了，我因此找到了经纪人，还得到了一点评论，诸如此类的事情。但我一直很好奇重新审视这些角色会是什么感觉。哦，你绝对会的。是的。就像30年后。哦，天哪，我太老了。不过，是的，珍娜太喜欢戏剧了，我女儿也是。我也喜欢戏剧，但我感觉自己在某种程度上变得更有耐心了，对待生活中娱乐的方式也是如此。
And so I have such patience that I want to go and see things now. and sit there and take it in. Yeah, yeah. I don't know. I feel like it's just so fun. There's nothing like theater, you know? You're speaking. This one's like, like, I'm going to a show tonight at the Pasadena Playhouse.
所以我现在有足够的耐心去观看演出。坐在那里细细品味。是的，是的。我不知道。我觉得这真的太有趣了。没有什么能比得上戏剧，你知道的？你在说。这个就像是，今晚我要去帕萨迪纳剧院看一场演出。
Oh, yeah. My husband. What are you going to see? It's this show called Mexodus. It's an original musical. Okay. He got us the tickets. That's a way to my heart.
哦，是的。我丈夫。你要去看什么？是一部叫《墨西哥大逃亡》的剧。这是一个原创音乐剧。好的。他给我们买的票。这正合我意。
Yeah. He's like, sweetie, there's a date night, date night, great new show. It's Pasadena Playhouse. Yeah. I love that. I love that. Do you ever think of doing theater, like performing a theater? Yes, I've done it.
是的。他说，亲爱的，今晚是约会之夜，约会之夜，一部很棒的新剧。在帕萨迪纳剧院。是的。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。你有没有想过演戏剧，比如进行戏剧表演？是的，我演过。
Yeah. But I hope to make it my habit. Yeah, yeah. I hope to make it my regular gig in the future. After my kids are grown. Yeah. We call it our third act. What's happening in your third act?
是的。但我希望把它变成我的习惯。是的，是的。我希望将来把它变成我的常态工作。等我的孩子长大了。是的。我们称之为我们的第三人生阶段。你的第三人生阶段在做什么？
Yeah. Jenna's going to be a lady on the theater. Yeah. That is the plan if I can make that happen. I've said this before. There's really two things I've always wanted to do. I've always wanted to be an actress and I've always wanted to be a parent. Yeah.
是的。珍娜要成为一个戏剧界的名媛了。是的，如果我能做到的话，这就是计划。我以前说过。我一直想做两件事：我一直想成为一名演员，我也一直想成为一名父母。是的。
And I was like, gosh, the parenting years, they're finite. And they only happen right here. Like the acting part can happen in many years when I'm 70, when I'm 75. But the parenting part is they go away. That's right. Eventually, they grow up. Yeah. And it happens so fast.
当时我想，天哪，当父母的几年是有限的。而且它们只在此时此地发生。就像演戏这部分可以在很多年里进行，当我70岁时，当我75岁时。但当父母这部分，他们会离开。没错。最终，他们会长大。是的。而且发生得太快了。
Yeah. So fast. And I'm like, I want to be here. And like selfishly, I want to do it all. Yeah, yeah. So, yeah, stepping back from acting in these last few years. But stepping back in now that I've, they're going into high school and middle. school. And we both kind of have itchy feet. But the podcast has been amazing because one of the
是的。太快了。我就想，我想留在这里。而且自私地说，我想两者兼得。是的，是的。所以，在过去几年里我从演戏中退了一步。但现在他们要上高中和初中了，我又重新投入进去了。而且我们俩都有点按捺不住了。但这个播客真的很棒，因为其中一
things we've always shared in our friendship was our love of family and family coming first. And having to be away just broke our hearts. So this community and this podcast has been so wonderful. Yeah. And it's so successful. It's like you guys are doing so great. And it seems like you would probably do this anyways. Like just hang out anyway. You're absolutely right. Because it's like if you are, are going to have a job where you get to hang out with your best friend in chat. This is it. Yeah. Because we were already doing that. Exactly. We might as well record it. Yeah, but yeah, that third act. That's like such a kind of exciting thing to think about. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Because
个我们友谊中一直共同坚守的东西就是对家庭的爱，家庭永远是第一位的。不得不离开（孩子）让我们心碎。所以这个社区和这个播客太美妙了。是的。而且它非常成功。感觉你们俩做得太棒了。而且看起来你们无论如何都会做这件事。就像无论如何都会一起闲逛一样。你说得完全对。因为如果你有一份工作，内容就是和你的闺蜜一起闲逛聊天。就是这个了。是的。因为我们本来就在做这件事。没错。我们不如把它录下来。是的，但是，第三人生阶段。那真是一个令人兴奋的想法。是的。是的。是的。因为
it could be anything. Could be anything. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, my gosh. Rian, this was lovely. So wonderful. Thank you for coming. Of course. Talking about your experience on the show. Yeah. Thank you for having me. It's just so wonderful to get that on record. Yes. It's on record. Yes. It's on record. And when you write your next play, if you need two ladies of a certain season in life.
那可能是任何事。可能是任何事。是的。是的。是的。哦，天哪。瑞恩，太美妙了。太棒了。谢谢你来。当然。谈谈你在剧中的经历。是的。谢谢你们邀请我。能把它记录下来真是太棒了。是的。记录在案了。是的。记录在案了。当你写下一部戏剧时，如果你需要两个处于人生某个特定阶段的女士。
Yep. Yeah. Yeah. It's you two. Yeah. They'd be like, why the older version of Angela and Pam in this play? It's a Korean family. Yes.
没错。是的。是的。就是你们俩。是的。他们会觉得，为什么在这部剧里安吉拉和帕姆是老年版本？这是一个韩裔家庭。是的。
And you two will, yeah, be the matriarchs. Yeah. Great, great. You can be your crazy neighbor. Yeah, yeah, yeah. We'll figure it out. We'll figure it out. Cookey neighbors.
然后你们俩，是的，将扮演女家长。是的。太棒了，太棒了。你可以演你那个疯狂的邻居。是的，我们会搞定的。我们会搞定的。古怪的邻居。
All right. Thank you so much. Thank you. Thank you guys. Well, he is just so delightful. That was so much fun. Okay, now it's time for Around the Town.
好了。非常感谢。谢谢。谢谢你们。他真是太可爱了。那太有趣了。好了，现在是“漫步小镇”环节。
I'll kick us off with this from Megan S in Troy, Ohio. Megan says in August, thousands of people from around the world descend upon Troy, Ohio, to celebrate the tour de donut by grace. Oh, boy. With a thousand dozen donuts, ladies. Megan says riders choose their course from the 9.72-mile donut hole to the 58.5-mile double-d challenge, which winds throughout the county. Each race includes pit stops for donuts,
我先来宣读来自俄亥俄州特洛伊市的梅根·S的来信。梅根说，在八月，来自世界各地数千人涌入俄亥俄州特洛伊市，参加格雷斯举办的“甜甜圈环城骑行”活动。哦，天哪。伴随着一千打甜甜圈，女士们。梅根说，骑手们可以从9.72英里的甜甜圈洞路线或58.5英里的双D挑战路线中选择自己的赛道，路线蜿蜒穿过整个县。每场比赛都设有甜甜圈补给站，
donated by a local bakery for each donut a rider eats and can keep down. Oh, oh, five minutes are deducted from their final time. A special stop called The Glazer gives out jelly or cream food. filled donuts, and riders can eat one of those to deduct 10 minutes from their time. Last year, I did the donut whole race with my nine-year-old son, Isaac, and between the two of us, we ate five donuts. Isaac is looking forward to beating both our donut and, less importantly, our time record this year. Wow. Wow. Okay. I could see, though, how that could take a turn. Yes, that you are now Michael Scott and you've eaten some fettuccini and you're going to run.
由当地面包店捐赠，骑手每吃掉一个并能消化吸收一个甜甜圈，哦，哦，最终成绩就会扣除五分钟。一个名为“糖霜”的特殊站点会分发果冻或奶油夹心甜甜圈，骑手可以吃其中一个来从成绩中扣除10分钟。去年，我和我九岁的儿子艾萨克一起参加了甜甜圈洞比赛，我们俩加起来吃了五个甜甜圈。艾萨克正期待着今年打破我们俩的甜甜圈数量纪录，以及更不重要的时间纪录。哇。哇。好吧。不过，我能想象这可能会演变成什么情况。是的，你现在成了迈克尔·斯科特，你吃了一些意大利面然后要去跑步。
I mean, I... This is very similar situation. I'm so curious, like, what's the average temperature for Troy, Ohio in August? I'm Googling it, Megan. I need to know how hot it is when you're riding around and eating these donuts. What does it say? Temperatures can average between 79 to 85 degrees. Well, that's not bad.
我的意思是，我……这情况非常相似。我很好奇，俄亥俄州特洛伊市八月的平均气温是多少？梅根，我正在谷歌搜索。我需要知道当你骑着车吃这些甜甜圈时有多热。上面怎么说？气温平均在79到85华氏度之间。嗯，那还不算太糟。
But still, that's pleasant. 80s on a bicycle. I didn't look up the humidity. Okay. I won't get into it. Way to go, Megan. I love that. I would just like to work the donut stand and maybe not be on the bicycle. You'd need to test the donuts to make sure. I would. I would make sure that they're good quality. Yeah. Yes. All right. Well, next up, Angela S from Athens, Pennsylvania said,
但即便如此，也很宜人。骑着自行车时是80多度。我没查湿度。好吧。我就不纠结了。干得好，梅根。我喜欢这个。我只想去甜甜圈摊工作，也许不用骑自行车。你需要测试甜甜圈以确保品质。我会的。我会确保它们的品质很好。是的。好吧，接下来，来自宾夕法尼亚州雅典娜的安吉拉·S说，
my home county, just a couple hours north of Scranton, recently hosted a beauty pageant for cows. Oh. Bradford County held the pasture perfect beauty pageant on June 20th. This event recreated a cow beauty contest that took place 100 years ago in the same location. Local farmers gathered in front of our county's courthouse with their most beautiful bovine. This year's winner, a red and white Holstein named Shakira received a floral crown as her prize. That is so sweet. That's so cute. And to wrap up our around the towns, here's something from Lucy I in Edinburgh,
我家乡的县，在斯克兰顿以北几个小时车程的地方，最近举办了一场奶牛选美比赛。哦。布拉德福德县于6月20日举办了“牧场完美”选美比赛。这项活动重现了100年前在同一地点举行为奶牛选美的盛会。当地农民带着他们最漂亮的纯种奶牛聚集在我们县法院前。今年的赢家是一头名叫夏奇拉的红白相间的荷斯坦奶牛，她戴上了花环作为奖品。太甜蜜了。太可爱了。为了结束我们的“漫步小镇”环节，这里有一封来自苏格兰爱丁堡、目前住在西班牙的露西·I的来信。
Scotland, but currently living in Spain. Lucy says, I'm on holiday in Spain at the moment and went to a town called Javier for a wee day trip, and we walked past a shoe shop called Shulala. Incredible. I was so excited to see Michael Scott's dream shoe shop name from Golden Ticket come true. I wonder if the owners are office fans. I also wonder how many people in the town have picked up on this connection. I mean, we clearly need to go to Spain and find out. And go to Shulala. Go to Shulala. You guys, thank you so much for writing in with your Around the Towns.
露西说，我目前正在西班牙度假，去了一个叫哈维尔的小镇进行了一日游，我们路过了一家叫“舒拉拉”的鞋店。太不可思议了。我很高兴看到迈克尔·斯科特在《金奖券》中梦想的鞋店名字成真了。我想知道店主是不是《办公室》的粉丝。我还想知道镇上有多少人注意到了这个联系。我的意思是，我们显然需要去西班牙一探究竟。去舒拉拉。去舒拉拉。各位，非常感谢你们写信来分享你们的“漫步小镇”故事。
Up next, we have our office question of the week. Yes, this is coming from Caton L. in St. Petersburg, Florida. Hello, Office Ladies. I am a longtime listener. I'm currently listening to your Office Trailers podcast. When I originally read the title, I accidentally thought you were talking about TV trailers. However, that made me think that I would love a discussion about how
接下来，我们有本周的“办公室问答”。是的，这封信来自佛罗里达州圣彼得堡的卡顿·L。哈喽，《办公室》女士们。我是一个老听众。我目前正在收听你们的《办公室预告片》播客。当我最初看到标题时，我误以为你们在谈论电视预告片。然而，这让我想到我很想听听关于
promotional videos, magazines, articles, TV interviews, all the things the office promotional materials came to be for the cast and crew. What does that process look like? Thank you. I love you. You two are sunshine to the world. Aw, thanks so much. That's so nice. Gosh, a lot goes into all of that. It is a little bit like a part-time job that gets attached to your full-time job, the full-time job being making the show or making a movie, whatever you made, there becomes this whole other job, which is promoting it, getting the word out about it, creating promotional materials. And you know, Katyn, depending on what project you're working on, there can be a whole team of people assigned to the marketing. So you might have a day where you go and you do a photo shoot,
宣传视频、杂志、文章、电视采访，以及《办公室》所有宣传材料是如何为演员和剧组诞生的讨论。这个过程是什么样的？谢谢。我爱你们。你们俩是照亮世界的阳光。哦，非常感谢。太暖心了。天哪，这一切背后包含了很多工作。它有点像是一份附加在你全职工作之上的兼职工作，全职工作就是制作这部剧或制作电影，无论你制作了什么，这里还有另一项完整的工作，那就是宣传它，宣传它，制作宣传材料。你知道的，卡顿，根据你正在合作的项目，可能会有一整支团队负责营销工作。所以你可能会有一天去进行一场照片拍摄，
right, with different people in the cast. And then also they might say, hey, could you guys take these phones and capture behind the scene content, or they'll send someone to capture behind the scene content. And then they use that and make it into little clips. And then you have a day where you talk to people who write on magazines. And then sometimes you go on TV shows, talk shows. It's a whole machine. Yeah. Before every new season, they would arrange some sort of full cast photo shoot on our set. And one year they set up a bunch of paper boxes in the break room. Yes. And a lot of you have seen that picture. Sure. Trying to fit us all in that break room, I don't think they thought that through. Well, I think that's why maybe the
对吧，和剧组不同的演员一起。然后他们也可能会说，嘿，你们能用这些手机捕捉一些幕后花絮内容吗，或者他们会派专人来捕捉幕后花絮内容。然后他们利用这些制作成小短片。然后你会有整整一天的时间去和那些为杂志写作的人交谈。有时你还会去上电视节目、脱口秀。这是一个完整的机器。是的。在每一季新开拍之前，他们会在我们的片场安排某种全剧组的合影拍摄。有一年，他们在休息室里摆了一堆纸盒。是的。很多人都见过那张照片。当然。要把我们所有人都塞进那个休息室里，我觉得他们当时没有考虑周全。嗯，我想这就是为什么也许在
following year, they put us all in the warehouse, yes, in front of a bunch of paper boxes. But they would have us do a group photo. They would put us in different pairings. They would have single photos. And that would be our morning. We would spend four or five hours just cycling through doing promotional photos, but we also had to be doing the show. So if you weren't getting your picture taken, then you were shooting a scene. And my goodness, if that wasn't a crazy scheduling job for Kelly Cantley and Rusty Mahmood, our ADs. And then also you would have sort of like a full-on press junket day and you would get paired up with someone. Jenna, you and I would get paired up together and we would have to be on set super early. You know, we would arrive at 3 a.m.
第二年，他们把我们都弄到了仓库里，是的，在一堆纸盒前面。但他们会让我们拍一张集体照。他们会把我们两两搭配。他们会拍单人照。那将是我们的早晨。我们会花四五个小时循环拍摄宣传照，但我们还得拍剧。所以如果你没有在拍照，那你就是在拍戏。天哪，这对于我们的副导演凯利·坎特利和拉斯蒂·马哈茂德来说，绝对是一项疯狂的排期工作。然后，你还得进行那种全方位的媒体日采访，你会和某个人搭档。珍娜，你和我会被分到一组，我们得超级早就到片场。你知道的，我们凌晨3点就到了
to be camera ready by 4 a.m. Yeah, and they'll sit you down in two chairs, and then you are via satellite to all these different live morning news programs, but those programs are starting on the East Coast as of 7 a.m. And you have the little thing in your ear, and you can hear the newscasters, you can't see them,
为了在凌晨4点做好上镜准备。是的，他们会让你坐在两把椅子上，然后你通过卫星连线到所有这些不同的早间直播新闻节目，但这些节目从东部时间早上7点就开始了。你的耳朵里塞着一个小东西，你能听到新闻主播的声音，你看不到他们，
you can hear them, and they're asking you questions, you do that for three minutes, and they're like, okay, and now we're going to New Hampshire, Yes, there's someone standing on set with you. And we often did these on the set of the office as our backdrop. But there was a person's role at NBC who would have a list of all the cities in the United States that we'd be popping on to their morning show. And they would say, all right, guys, up next, Toledo, Ohio.
你能听到他们的声音，他们向你提问，你持续三分钟，然后他们会说，好的，现在我们要去新罕布什尔州了，是的，片场会有人和你站在一起。我们经常在《办公室》片场以其为背景做这些连线。但在NBC有一个人的职责是手里拿着一张美国各个城市的名单，我们会出现在这些城市的早间节目中。他们会说，好了，各位，接下来是俄亥俄州托莱多。
And three, two, one, you're alive, right? And then it would be like, up next, you're on with St. Louis, Missouri. And three, two, one, and on and on. And by the end, you have no idea who you're talking to anymore. And also, by the way, if you need to go to the bathroom, you got to hold it. Yeah. They would have little breaks that they would work in. And there'd usually be a slightly larger break where you could get some breakfast
三，二，一，你们直播了，对吧？然后会是，接下来，你们要连线密苏里州圣路易斯。三，二，一，诸如此类，没完没了。到了最后，你根本不知道自己在和谁说话。而且，顺便说一句，如果你需要上厕所，你得憋着。是的。他们会穿插安排一些小休息时间。通常还会有一个稍微长一点的休息时间，你可以吃点早餐
while you waited for all of the West Coast news programs to start at actual 7 a.m. And then after you did that, you started your regular workday. Yeah. So we would be there for three hours and then go into our regular workday. And, you know, everyone was always so gracious, but I do have a new appreciation for everyone that ever has to call in or pop in via satellite to a talk show because there is that delay. And I'm sure all of y'all listening have seen this before. Someone's on your news program and they pop in. And the person asks the question like, all right, can you tell us about this new season of your TV show?
当你等待所有西海岸的新闻节目在真正的早上7点开始时。然后做完这些之后，你就开始你的正常工作日了。是的。所以我们在那里呆了三个小时，然后开始我们正常的工作日。而且，你知道的，每个人总是那么亲切，但我对所有曾经不得不打电话或通过卫星连线加入脱口秀节目的人有了全新的感激之情，因为那里面有延迟。我确信在听节目的所有人以前都见过这个。某人上了你们的新闻节目，然后他们连线了。然后主持人问了一个问题，比如，好的，你能跟我们聊聊你们电视剧的新季吗？
And then they're like, yes, I can't, I'm sorry. Yeah, it's like so clunky sometimes. And they haven't fixed that, which is funny. There's a delay and it's always a little tricky. But anyway, it is a lot of moving parts, the way shows and movies come together and the promotion. I have a lot of respect for all the different departments. Yeah. But it has to get folded into your already very busy work week.
然后他们说，是的，我不能，对不起。是的，有时就是这么尴尬。而且他们还没解决这个问题，这很有趣。有延迟，而且总是有点棘手。不管怎样，这有很多活动部件，剧集和电影的制作过程以及宣传。我非常尊重所有不同的部门。是的。但这必须融入你本来就已经非常繁忙的工作周中。
And all of that scheduling would have to go through the producers if someone needed to go do a taping of the tonight show. We would have to move the whole schedule around because the rest of us would still be filming. And none of those late night talk shows are filmed late at night. That's correct. They're filmed at like 5 p.m. or 4 p.m. You know, it's like late afternoon. So a workday is still happening half the time. Well, and one of the things that would be tricky for me, and Angela, I'm sure this was true for you as well, not so much for the gentleman. But our hair as our characters of Angela and Pam was very specific. But if I was going to go be a guest on a late night talk show and wear like a cute little dress or whatever and, you know, it didn't work.
如果有人需要去录制《今夜秀》，所有这些排期都必须通过制片人。我们必须调动整个日程，因为我们其余的人还得继续拍摄。而且这些深夜脱口秀节目都不是在深夜拍摄的。没错。它们是在下午5点或4点左右拍摄的。你知道的，就像是下午晚些时候。所以一半的时间里工作日还在继续。嗯，对我来说比较棘手的一件事情是，安吉拉，我确信对你来说也是如此，对男士们来说倒没那么明显。但我们作为安吉拉和帕姆的角色发型是非常具体的。但如果我要去上深夜脱口秀节目，穿一件可爱的小裙子或者别的什么，你知道的，这行不通。
I would have to be depammed. I know. And you would have to be D. Angela Martin. I know. I didn't want to go on a late night talk show with a bun with a severe bun. Exactly. Maybe I should have one time. Well, there was one thing, and I can't remember what it is now off the top of my head,
我必须得“去帕姆化”。我懂。而你必须得“去安吉拉·马丁化”。我懂。我可不想顶着一个发髻，一个严厉的发髻去上深夜脱口秀节目。没错。也许我应该有一次那样做。嗯，有一件事，现在我一下子想不起来是什么了，
where we had something we had to go to, Angela. I feel like it was a panel that we all had to talk on after work, but we went late, and Kim Ferry was just like, Jenna, the best I can do is throw that hair up into like a crazy ponytail for you. Otherwise, you're going to have Pam hair. I was like, do the ponytail. Do the ponytail. I went to an award show in my Angela Martin ponytail because we filmed so late. Yes.
我们在那儿有不得不去的地方，安吉拉。我觉得那是一个座谈会，下班后我们所有人都必须去发言，但我们去晚了，金·费瑞直接就说，珍娜，我能做的最好的事就是把你的头发随手扎成一个疯狂的马尾辫。否则，你就会顶着帕姆的发型。我说，扎马尾。扎马尾。我顶着安吉拉·马丁的马尾辫去参加了一个颁奖典礼，因为我们拍戏太晚了。是的。
I can't remember which one it was. The Golden Globes, I was in a red dress and I'm in my Angela Martin ponytail because I didn't have time. With the swoop bang. Yes. Well, there you go. Thanks for asking that question. That's a little bit behind the scenes. We love hearing from you guys.
我不记得是哪一个了。金球奖，我穿着一件红裙子，顶着安吉拉·马丁的马尾辫，因为我没时间。带着那个标志性的刘海。是的。好吧，就是这样。谢谢你提出那个问题。那是一点幕后花絮。我们很喜欢听你们分享。
I'll put a swipe up in our stories where you can write us. And a huge thank you to Randall Park for coming into the studio with us today. Yes, it was so generous of him to come in the studio and speak with us today. Thank you, Randall. Everyone, be sure to check him out. He's everywhere, okay? Look for him in AMCs the Audacity. Look for him in these two indie films, Brian and Wishful Thinking.
我会在我们的快拍里放一个上滑链接，你们可以在那里给我们写信。非常感谢兰道尔·帕克今天来到我们的录音室。是的，他今天能来到录音室和我们交流真是太慷慨了。谢谢你，兰道尔。大家一定要去关注他。他无处不在，好吗？去AMC的《无畏》中找他。去独立电影《布莱恩》和《一厢情愿》中找他。
And then, of course, there's a show that I am obsessed with. I'm late to the party, but I'm obsessed, which is the residence on Netflix. And for you folks out there that love a rom-com, as much as me and Matt Beagle to. Check out his 2019 movie. Always Be My Maybe. It's so fun. And you get a little Keanu Reeves.
当然，还有我痴迷的那部剧。我虽然后知后觉，但我迷上了，那就是奈飞的《白宫谋杀案》。对于你们这些和我以及马特·比格尔一样喜欢浪漫喜剧的朋友们。去看看他2019年的电影《别担心我》。太有趣了。里面还能看到基努·里维斯。
All right, everyone. Thank you so much. We'll see you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Pfeiffer.
好了，各位。非常感谢。我们下周见。到时见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是Audience出品的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的高级制作人是马特·比格尔，音频工程师是山姆·普法伊夫。
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies. was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Rupertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Audience执行制作人是利亚·里瑟·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《鲁珀特树》。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。